this is not a Palestinian Israeli
conflict this is an issue of Truth
Versus Falsehood between God and Satan
I'm sorry I'm just going to make it like
that that's just the way it is between
the truth of of Islam and submission to
the Creator and the will of the Creator
andan that's just the way it is where is
the truth not just the truth of okay
who's the perpetrator but the truth of
this world the truth of Allah the truth
of of the Creator that's what we need to
go back to to understand that this is
done is because humanity is not
submitting to the one who created them
they're making their own rules their own
laws their own ideas and it leads to
chaos in the world